[Musique]
eh bien Georgia voit Andy Serkis l'exhorte à
jouer sur elle pour être ici en France
ouvrant l'aube de la planète des
singes cela reprend maintenant l'histoire dix
ans plus tard il y a eu une énorme pandémie
qui a anéanti la majeure partie de l'humanité mais
là  sont des poches de survivants César
a créé cette société presque ils Dilek
avec environ deux mille huit
ils croient que les êtres humains
ont disparu maintenant qu'ils sont tous morts
ce qui se passe au début de ce
film est que tout à coup ils arrivent
j'ai besoin de justice César  César est un
sympathisant de l'humanité parce qu'il a été
élevé avec eux alors que les autres
singes ont tous souffert aux mains des
humains, donc la pression qu'il subit
ressort vraiment lorsque les êtres humains
se présentent, ce film examine vraiment l'
empathie, il examine la famille tribale et
surmonter les conflits potentiels c'est une
pièce d'ensemble très riche cela ne veut pas dire
qu'une espèce est meilleure que l'autre
nous disons que les deux sont potentiellement
responsables  pour l'avenir de la terre,
Matt Reeves est le
réalisateur d'acteurs le plus incroyable, il est tout au sujet de l'
intimité du drame et du
processus organique de recherche de personnage, trouvant
ce qui est vraiment important à
chaque instant de chaque scène lorsque
j'ai commencé à travailler dans le domaine de la
performance  capturer c'était vraiment une
quantité inconnue il n'y avait pas de modus
operandi il n'y avait aucune idée que
cela fonctionnerait même au cours
des 14 dernières années environ cela a réuni les
acteurs pour que vous n'ayez à
tourner qu'une fois ce n'est vraiment rien d'
autre  qu'une manière différente d'enregistrer
la performance des acteurs, mais ce que cela
m'a permis de faire, c'est d'errer dans
un autre monde et pourquoi je l'aime en tant que
technologie, c'est à quel point c'est libérateur que
vous êtes entièrement libéré par elle, tout dépend
de votre imagination  et étant capable de
grimper à l'intérieur de n'importe lequel de ces rôles,
je suis ravi que nous soyons en mesure de vous
apporter cette prochaine version de l'aube de la
planète des singes parce que je
je pense que c'est avant tout c'est un
film très divertissant mais très
important il
porte beaucoup de sens c'est un
film très émouvant je pense que je pense
qu'il résonnera avec beaucoup de gens partout
dans le monde et je pense que c'est pourquoi
ces films  supportent encore aujourd'hui toute la
franchise parce qu'ils ont
élevé leurs perceptions intelligentes
de la capacité de voir le monde des êtres
humains à travers les yeux des singes, alors
j'espère que vous apprécierez